I'd take 150 pills which is maybe 70 or
80 different things this is different
story and each one although people find
that a very aggressive program it's
actually very conservative because
everything I do is actually has a lot of
evidence as aging is not one thing it's
many different things coenzyme q10 is
very important particularly at my age as
an antioxidant phosphatidylcholine it
addresses all by itself a major aging
process because that substance depletes
from your cell membrane and that's why
the skin in an elderly person loses
suppleness and your organs don't work
very well
I throw in vitamin D and it's very
important that's maybe the most
important vitamin to take and there's
tremendous amount of research and a
consensus that that really does help
prevent cancer and other diseases